dröhnendes schweigen aus dem Auswärtigen
Amt seit gestern nur sehr übersichtliche
Mitteilungen wie wir beobachten sehr
aufmerksam und stehen in engstem
Austausch mit unseren internationalen
Partnern Schweigen diplomatische
Zurückhaltung am Tag eins nach dem
Putschversuch
auch Bundeskanzler Scholz geht nicht
raus an die Öffentlichkeit müssen die
Ereignisse erst auf höchster Ebene
sortiert werden was wusste der
Bundesnachrichtendienst überhaupt bis
zuletzt galt beim BND die Einschätzung
Putin sitze fest im Sattel ich vermute
schon dass wir alle überrascht gewesen
sind Russland Essen ständiges Mitglied
im Sicherheitsrat ist das nuklear macht
und am Ende gelingt es de facto eine
Frage der Truppe bis kurz vor die
Hauptstadt zu gehen natürlich ist es im
Shop auch ich will die Zurückhaltung der
Bundesregierung in der Öffentlichkeit
zunächst mal wohl wollen werden als der
Versuch eine abgestimmte Haltung zu
entwickeln und vor allem erstmal
Sachverhaltsaufklärung zu betreiben
allein die Tatsache dass auch die
deutsche Bundesregierung offensichtlich
zu überrascht worden ist ist natürlich
ein Alarmzeichen
nur 200 Kilometer vor Moskau wendet sich
gestern der Vormarsch in den Rückzug der
wagnertruppen der Kreml gewährt den
Söldnern Amnestie Anführer prigoschin
auf dem Weg vom südrussischen Roßdorf
aus ins Exil begleitet von Jubel Bilder
der russischen staatlichen
nachrichtenagenturia Belarus Machthaber
Lukas Schinko hatte den Deal eingefädelt
die Lage bleibt unklar und ist weiter
instabil
wir werden so eine Art Serie erleben wir
haben jetzt sozusagen den die Pilotfolge
gesehen und das ist der Beginn
eigentlich einen eines nachfolgekampfes
um den Platz der starken Mannes in der
Russischen Föderation der war gestern so
schwach wie bisher noch nie es ist für
mich ganz klar das weiß ich nicht
derjenige sein wird dem man das
Vertrauen für die Zukunft Russland
schenken wird nicht in der Bevölkerung
wenn ich in der Elite wenn es jemand
gibt der mit diesem Putsch geschwächt
ist dann ist das Wladimir Putin alle
Welt hat gesehen dass er Russland eben
nicht beherrscht und das ist
insbesondere für die Bevölkerung mehr
als ein Zeichen es kann sein dass dieser
Tag wirklich der Anfang vom Ende von
Wladimir Putin war die AFD die erst
kürzlich vom Verfassungsschutz
bescheinigt bekommen hat Lautsprecher
der putinpropaganda zu sein ihre
Bundespartei Spitze äußert sich nicht
trotz wiederholter anfragen zu den
Ereignissen in Russland nur gestern der
rechtsextreme Björn höcke aus Thüringen
die Falken in Washington sollten sich
allerdings nicht zu früh freuen wenn
Putin fällt könnte sein Nachfolger
wesentlich radikaler operieren als der
vom Westen zur Ausgeburt des Bösen
erklärte derzeitige Kremlchef
der Aufstand der Söldner der kein Putsch
wurde wirft aus Sicht der
spd-anschlaglicht auf die Schwäche
Putins und die seines Militärs Schwäche
als Chance eine Aufforderung für mehr
Deutsche Waffenlieferung
wir müssen insgesamt schneller werden
und wir müssen noch mehr zur Verfügung
stellen vor allem im Hinblick auf die
Munition wenn es in diesem Jahr nicht
gelingt diesen Krieg zu Gunsten der
Ukraine zu entwickeln dann wird es sehr
sehr schwer denn jetzt ist Putin
angreifbar putin ist schwach wenn das in
Moskau den die Folge hat dass man sich
geschwächt fühlt dann schlägt vielleicht
die russische Regierung um zu zeigen
dass sie immer noch da ist in den in der
kommenden Zeit erst recht in der Ukraine
zu also ich warne vor der Vorstellung
dass eine von uns jetzt unterstellte
politisch militärische Schwächung
Russlands automatisch zu einer
Verbesserung der Lage an der Ukraine von
führt Ende offen die Bundesregierung hat
es jetzt möglicherweise mit einem
anderen Wladimir Putin zu tun wie
demütigt und dadurch noch aggressiver
als ohnehin schon die militärische
spezialoperation gegen die Ukraine hat
zu den Kreml Chef weiterhin höchste
Priorität
und zugeschaltet aus Düsseldorf ist uns
jetzt die Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses guten Abend
Frau streikt Zimmermann guten Abend nach
Berlin Präsident Putin musste gestern im
Fernsehen öffentlich machen dass seine
Macht nicht unendlich ist was heißt denn
diese erste Demütigung vor der ganzen
Nation für ihn
also was ich wenn ich das sage sagen
darf spannend finde ist dass er sehr
schnell als diese wagnergruppe
gewissermaßen vor den Toren Moskau stand
in die Öffentlichkeit gegangen ist wir
wissen dass die Russen wenig
Informationen bekommen gerade zu
entpolitisiert sind und nun geht er vor
die Öffentlichkeit spricht von Verrat
von Durchstoß und wenige Stunden später
lässt er die denen er den Verrat
vorgeworfen hat lässt er die einfach so
gehen das bekommen natürlich auch
Menschen mit die nicht so politisch
interessiert sind und informiert sind
insofern ist das wirklich ein schwarzer
Tag für Putin was daraus wird das ist
natürlich sehr viel Spekulation aber
interessant zu beobachten ist das
allemal gehen sie denn davon aus dass
Putin ab sofort ein zwei Fronten Krieg
führen muss ihnen und außenpolitisch
ja das sehe ich so er muss also erstmal
zeigen dass er in der Ukraine präsent
ist wir wissen dass er ja geglaubt hatte
dieses Land in drei Wochen in der Tasche
zu haben der Westen steht die NATO steht
wird erweitert all das damit hat er ja
nicht gerechnet auch das über 50 Staaten
die Ukraine unterstützen so und jetzt
ist da wo er bisher war meistens im
Keller sitzen das war ja schon bei
Corona so vor dem Virus hat er auch
Sorge dass er plötzlich jetzt ja das
Gefühl haben muss das möglicherweise da
auch in der wagnergruppe jemand ein
Kontakt hat rigosh ihn zum Kremel
möglicherweise auch das ist Spekulation
und das muss ihn beunruhigen denn machen
wir uns nichts vor das ist ja kein
Knabenchor mit dem wir es zu tun haben
das sind ja alles Verbrecher und dass
der eine oder der andere nur darauf
wartet dass Putin schwächelt da kann er
ziemlich von ausgehen die Frage wird
sein wird derjenige den Mut haben oder
dauert das noch Wochen oder Monate das
werden wir beobachten wie sollte denn
der Westen jetzt mit Putin umgehen oder
sollten wir überhaupt nicht ändern
nein ich glaube wir sollten gar nichts
ändern unsere Konzentration soll doch
darauf liegen so schnell wie möglich der
Ukraine weiterhin zu helfen Munition ran
zu schaffen was Michael Roth gerade sagt
es doch völlig richtig das Problem ist
doch das Putin immer auf Zeit gespielt
hat nach dem Motto irgendwann macht der
Westen sich doch dünner und unterstützt
die Ukraine nicht mehr und genau
deswegen müssen wir alles Erdenkliche
tun was wir können wir können nicht
alles aber das was wir tun können
gemeinsam mit den Partnern die Ukraine
nach wie vor unterstützen daran ändert
sich überhaupt nichts und alles weitere
ist ein innerrussischer Konflikt und da
bin ich der Meinung da tut die
Bundesregierung gut daran in diesem Fall
das nicht zu kommentieren von der
Seitenlinie sondern abzuwarten was
passiert wir haben jetzt gelernt die
Geheimdienste waren überrascht vom
Überfall auf die Ukraine und
offensichtlich auch jetzt wieder und die
Lage Einschätzung war stets Putin hat
alles unter Kontrolle der scheint ja
noch deutlich Luft nach oben bei unseren
Diensten
ja es ist nicht nur unser Dienst unser
Dienst arbeitet ja mit anderen zusammen
und das ist nicht das erste Mal dass wir
überrascht werden dass eine Situation
eine völlig andere ist als die die man
uns berichtet insofern dass es
offensichtlich alle Dienste betrifft
zeigt dass es im Creme offensichtlich
ein Machtblock gibt wo nichts
raussickert und nicht mal die Dienste in
irgendeiner Form Informationen bekommen
und sollte nur klar sein dass da jetzt
Bewegung ist und dass die Dienste da
unter Umständen Nachholbedarf haben was
Informationen betrifft das steht mir
nicht zu aber ich würde es dringend
empfehlen Putin weiß sich an der Ukraine
die Zähne aus die eigenen Paramilitärs
gegen gehen gegen ihn vor im größeren
historischen Bild war dass der Angriff
auf die Ukraine der Anfang vom Ende
Putins
ich glaube dass er sich in seinem
imperialistischen machtwahnsinn
komplette fergaloppiert hat das fing ja
schon am Anfang an dass das alles nicht
so lief das auch seine Armee nicht die
Stärke die Potenz hat die ja auch
Russland uns immer zu übermitteln
versuchte und insofern ich glaube das
war der Moment das Momentum zu viel und
zu groß und er hat eben nicht damit
gerechnet dass der Westen an der Seite
der Ukraine steht und dass die Ukraine
für ihr Land kämpfen
in diesem Kontext ist er schon
angeschlagen und angezählt im Kremel
weil ihm das eben nicht so schnell
gelungen ist wie er das geglaubt hat
dass es das gelingt ich danke für Ihre
Einschätzung herzlichen Dank und Gruß
nach Düsseldorf ich danke Ihnen